hi guys my name is Cameron chambers and
this is Taylor chambers my little
brother my younger brother I guess yeah
and this is cameras never seen we are
watching it for the first time we're
trying to decide which version to watch
honestly it's hard I'm going to put the
ITV fundamentals oh I was for physic
okay I'm hoping that it's creepy it's
Stephen King which is kind of hit or
miss for me it's three hours long it's
three hours long three hours long why
are the three hours why are you gonna do
this to us they're gonna do the whole
book I guess tinkering better be an a
lot it's one of the ones like yeah yes
we did
that's what most of Tamra's never seen
it so no there we go okay that was long
the first half was like cool love this
backstory second half was kind of like a
just like a jumbled mess of like oh my
god yeah after yeah after they started
to like wrap up the kids part of it
you're like oh now they're gonna resolve
a whole nother thing and the adult
actors are way worse than the children I
yeah yeah they're not good I kiss
monologue help me like yeah man I will I
will help you with your and then he gets
off ponytail and it's just everything to
ruin unlike seen them the movie starts
off and the little girl dies does he
like either like Mangler or like just
like clown thing there's like six kids
missing and my channe limb is like oh
shit
it is back right because he's so round
in the town my oh oh mike deserves
better does this clown okay let's kill
it alright well I'm gonna stay here for
the rest of my life who is that
explain it but it was yeah I'm Betty
calls bill I don't like bill I know
you're something like though right off
the bat like he's noticeably a really
bad actor
George calm down bill calm down not to
make fun of stutters making fun of Bill
let's me said very good about Bill is
sick so Georgie goes out and plays at
the boat
oh well Georgie is running down the
street going beep beep both beep beep
both don't beat Georgie yeah you'll
never be a seaman like that right off
the bat see penny wise and at first I'm
skiing penny wise before obviously it's
like an iconic villain but I wasn't
super into the design I was like I just
not scared at all by clowns and then he
starts saying things in a weird cadence
he kind of changes how he says certain
words and the whole they all float
Georgie the coolest part is that the
parents don't see any of it I love it
it's just kids did love to do like
bullies
like the kids they had for it to work
like evil Santa yeah yeah it was cool
the way they made the blood work though
all the practical than in the movie are
really nice yeah then you're introduced
to Ben as a child then you meet Henry
who is a sociopath who was like all of
this disturbing is penny wise thank he's
like making fun of a bend for his weight
Henry get a job oh then you meet any you
see asthma kid because you can tell
because he has the asthma what did you
say both ways there was a top 10 things
you may have missed in the new 8 trailer
on YouTube and none of them were
surprising at all they were all things
that was like none of us miss any of
that kid you see here's an inhaler she's
probably the one with asthma really ed
he looks like a little mini businessman
go go she's like the flashback of been
seeing his father in like the swamp area
you need to turn up the contrast of like
really like lights and darks is like
kind of eerie and then slowly you get
like the clown pop a set another balloon
it's just it's done well that was super
creepy on but then Ben just goes along
your merry way not to tell anyone ever
and then you see Beverly Beverly grown
up she lives in Chicago with her abusive
boyfriend Tom she doesn't think he
doesn't like and then he's like come on
over here booty pants down or whatever
he's got like a belt like he's gonna
spank her
yeah she's like no not that again it's
like oh god what is been transpiring
hell if it started off as like a kink
and then turned into something bad or if
it was just always he was a bad person
so then you see Beverly in her bathroom
and like the blood comes out of her sink
and her dad doesn't see it rose he's a
dick too just like the other dude that's
probably why there's like the chain
anyway
Pennywise like yelling you'll die if you
die physically horrifying to hear as a
child I feel like yeah but you don't
know that you have any actual power and
so if someone says you'll die if you try
you believe that oh then the next kid
seen was the shower Eddy scene and all
of the awesome so that was really cool
also there's a cut spidery and almost
like it's true for yeah it must have
been just like people backing him
through but to us it's like and then the
like claymation like him opening up the
drain popping out was cool so then you
see Ritchie who is now a famous comedian
he's not funny you just yell yeah the
authority isn't likable at all the young
Richie I really dug yeah and they're
calling everyone and it's like
assembling the world son x-men they're
all getting together because they
promised they would return if Pennywise
ever came back
shit yeah ah crap so I want you to
pretend that Taylor's head is a balloon
and I'm gonna act like Michael as an
adult already got it reacting to a blue
all right see I bet in your mind okay
but it's just a balloon Michael Michael
mom dad okay you're doing good now okay
switch switch roles so we go into Killa
into the sewer system and at this point
we're like oh how much time is left half
half of it is gone oh we're halfway
there
oh I use not a chair okay
the belt seemed like magazine to come
[Laughter]
that kind of that's what happens and
then Pennywise shows its Pennywise form
and just like I eat kids Wow Eddie comes
in with battery acid and you're like
what oh oh
did Eddie get battery acid they don't
explain that so so much later that it's
just the power of imagination left up to
the eyes of a holder and so he's like
battery and it's so work and I'm so
bored anyways like devastated by a face
is melted save the day told Benny looks
like al Borland he said Tim oldest
friend
[Laughter]
creepy moment
Bev's comes back and she goes to her
childhood home and it's old woman is
living there and it's all woman gifts to
the news of her father's died and that's
like okay it's kinda weird
unless you know two wizards woman eats
turkey three two
hey guys I want to know who that actress
is she really went for it
I want to know what are the rules then
bad sees all of her childhood friends
walks into the room ago one group of
handsome men and then faint
damn girl needs the d damn there's
Darvin scene he's got water the fortune
cookies were cool and they were all
different which is neat and I love it
they had to like play it off like
nothing was wrong because no one else
can see them yeah okay Ben and Bev
hadn't gotten together
I wrote they kiss oh and then you
realize that it's Pennywise but it's sad
I feel so bad for so twisted up of all
the things that's like the most yeah
like bodily contact but like Samuel oh
then he's got like the makeup on him oh
that's me bad boy that was another thing
we were saying in the beginning we see
adult then he's telling this like really
beautiful woman's he woke up with he's
like I should be so fat she wouldn't
believe just believe it
oh yeah so fast so bad and he just
embellishing and he's probably like
that's cool I believe you from the first
time buddy go back down into the pipes
to take you up anyway and once and for
all they've decided it's it was such a
ride of like uh we're not going to do
anything okay we're definitely not going
to doing I'm gonna leave and then we're
definitely good doing it we were doing
yeah he's such a little person yeah and
you just want to let everyone know like
I've never had sex because I've never
loved someone
except for you all I love you all like
what is the movie just turned into a
five phone
[Music]
then I wrote you guys a version they
bully the monster to death yeah they
figured out we can just kind of
manhandle it in collision let's just
kick it it's not really got a lot of
defenses who supplies the scary it's
like a turtle
it was so anticlimactic yeah the way
they actually handled it I mean they did
again it's just belief but like they
just had to believe they could I guess
ah I just didn't like the age-old
portions of this at all except for Benny
I like Benny a lot but he was great yeah
Betty in bed says I'm alright with that
yeah and I did like adult Eddie and
Michael was fine but he had some weird
moments of acting it was enjoyable there
were definite moments of it getting
under your skin whereas creepy in a
great way it wasn't scary to me but I
enjoyed like the creepy undertones I
really think the new ones going to be
scary
you will have moved to Chicago yeah I'm
just I'm I'm this year now so we are
gonna be doing some videos together on
my personal channel one of them soon
[Music]
[Applause]
you